hello everybody good morning we are here
it's Tuesday
I'm Persia I'm joined by max today and
we are gonna play some Mortal Kombat 11
why you ask because Arnold is in the
game big boy is here The Terminator is
here we're excited and you need the
combat pack though to play him right now
yeah the characters a week early for
each launch as long as you have a combat
pack so we have a combat pack and now
we're going to learn some Terminator and
whenever it comes to learning stuff and
fighting in it's loud you just have to
hit the lab right that's that's facts
first thing I do is I try to research
combos that's all I do exactly you know
you gotta find them combos gotta learn
the moves just see what's good or not so
it only makes sense we're gonna go learn
some things but before we had to
practice mode a tutorial we want to see
the fatalities all right let's start
with some fatality training we're on ps4
we didn't we do have the character
available to us right now through the
combat pack so I do see some people in
the chat saying they can't use them not
sure if you're on the ps4 or not but
he's available for us right now with
combat this is always something
interesting to me and Mortal Kombat is
like which variation should we choose I
don't know but we'll just go with the
default one for now there were some
other cool looking skins on the Mortal
Kombat's yeah and I've watched a few
videos of the like fatalities being done
to the Terminator and
has like the metal skeleton on that
which is like really fun yeah that's
pretty cool I just feel like this stage
is fitting for him but yeah yeah let us
know guys how's everything looking and
sounding at the moment I think we're all
good to go on that end but yeah let's do
this I'm gonna disable a fatality
timeout so I can have maximum time to do
these all right so we gotta be close
real close like almost toes touching and
yeah back forward back
oh I stepped out of it but it's good
nice calm cool and collected - he just
did that with no stress Terminator one
no don't ask me oh man I need to
re-watch those those movies are so old
first came out and then I never saw them
again
I need to rewatch them and get a
refresher on them so I haven't unlocked
the second one so I guess I can't do
that one yeah yeah until they unlock it
womp womp it's okay we'll do this one
one more time unless somebody knows the
input I think you can do it without
knowing the input yeah you can't
actually if somebody knows the input -
fatality - let us know we will do a
quick little search just because I want
to see it sometimes you could tell the
command just by like seeing how they
move reality because this kind of guess
there's a lot of teabagging and it's
probably or if it's like back and forth
like a left-right all right all right
I'm just doing some research here you
guys no worries
um all right that's the one we already
saw
ooh the second one looks super oh yeah
it's the yeah okay let's see what Sigma
did it didn't like yeah it was like I
don't know oh did he do the easy one
oh that was easy fatality no I mean
we're dry or we're trying to what amen I
wanted to see it it looks cool to you I
don't want to spoil it for you guys
darn it could use the coin to unlock it
oh and the Crypt rate
I think somebody isn't that orangie I
know Ben would know I know Ben I'm
definitely not the more I got a peek of
its here use the fatality claim is that
in this uh in this section though yeah I
know I don't lab this game enough that's
for sure yeah you know what it's fine we
will find it out before the end of the
stream we have ample amounts of time
right now the only time I sure can look
up some combos to you tutorial okay yeah
so uh oh
use the crane for the easy fatality wait
no I was just in there okay well I won't
be safe that's fine as long as we get to
see it
all right let's see what this game has
to teach us he looks so good
he does look it's very much Arnold yeah
which I like they definitely got that
you have to use it in a normal fight
yeah yeah yeah of course this the first
one was already automatically unlocked
for us the notations anyways Caroline
asked available now yes I'm ps4 it is
learn some things deep deep deep so only
for combat pack and only for ps4 right
now rights not sure if Xbox is just
coming out a little bit later in the day
all right the Terminator is an offensive
character that wants to stay close to
this target he has a variety of mix-ups
to break through his opponents defense
and terminate the worst thank you for
using that penance absolutely amazing
sawed-off uses a terminator shotgun so
why are a high projectile attack that
hits at any range this attack will deal
more damage when the Terminator is
closer to his opponent interesting ok
amplify sawed off after the first shot
to retreat while firing an additional ok
ok kill alright
smooth he's like he's got the gun play
on point for sure
it could be further amplified by
spinning the other half of his offensive
gauge alright yeah sort of ok did we see
the Cassie Quinn skin yes it's actually
really cute - I'll put it on for you
guys when I go into training training
mode amplified sadiq can be directed
forward after the first or second shot
okay so it doesn't only go back oops I
didn't press the button
nice it's like a nice little
intimidating step forward yeah I got it
oh I wonder if I could do the first one
back in the second one for me yeah can
you mix it up and I can do it back and
forth
oh I'm out of gauge I guess we could do
the actual mood they want us to do okay
oh my god because I land like on the
neck yeah dubby dubby any stuff right
there oh I was like that wasn't the news
um Mike asked can i play with terminator
right now he did by the combat pack are
you on ps4 xbox because ps4 is available
but we have seen that Xbox is coming out
a little bit later so while holding down
after it connects to leave the opponent
close and standing the terminator will
have frame advantage oh snap okay okey I
see oh okay let's do it yeah cuz the
other one Chuck them hecka far which
wasn't really good for mix-up outdoors
oh yeah it does that little stagger
state at the end is like really good
hold it
oh boy doing square nice play on too
many different consoles X and like you
know B and stuff there they get switched
up completely eliminate all humanity
starts with a quick high attack and all
three hits are safe on block that's what
I like to see it when I'm learning a
character all three hits are safe on
block let's go this combo attack can be
easily hit confirm into a special move
sounds like a pretty darn good move if
you ask me oh nice another one of those
pretty normal strings I misread that is
overhead it was just a high ataxic
conductor yeah
catastrophic crash starts with a fast
short-range mid attack hit confirm into
a special move up at the second hit or
execute all three attacks to punish the
opponent back and remain safe on block
all you know thumbs down but looked cool
always like a hairy man grabs there we
go
gives them some distance say goodbye
begins with an overhead attack there we
go we've got no red in there now
overhead attack ends with a block Abul
throw attack oof that the opponent must
duck to avoid this combo attack can be
easily punished if it misses means
unsafe on block or innocence
this is the t800 terminator and what's
up crime has gone hammer slammer
followed by unblockable throat ah that
hits airborne opponents ooh
this attack is difficult to punish one
block okay which means it's not 100%
safe but it might be like neutral yeah
or like negative one which which is
pretty good gotcha
nice and easy no escape I want to be in
the meeting room when these guys are
thinking of these move name starts with
a low and followed by an overhead noise
but safe on block and launches for a
juggle combo on hit okay this sounds
like my kind of move yes yeah any
launcher is all me oh I see I see
there's a gap between the two attacks so
if you if you see it coming and you
blocked first it you can interrupt with
a hit in between as long as you move as
fast enough okay you can jab between a
problem yeah oh wait yeah I was like I
keep pressing square instead of it swap
the second hint of no escape for
unstoppable machine to perform
perform a faster mid attack to counter
anyone who's trying to interrupt that
string like we're talking about
difficult to punish on block and it will
knock down on hit which means more okie
oh snap
interesting crime said I'll never
understand why you like doing tutorials
because you learn a lot about the
character actually like right now we're
learning some really useful things that
he can use in neutral and not only like
good moves but the cons to those moves
too like we just learned at a low
overhead which is great but it's also
interrupt a bull which is great to know
when you're using it and then they
follow up by showing you an alternative
string that doesn't have a gap so you
can even more mix up the opponent and
that's all off of like a generic
tutorial loop for the character that
is actually really really good and
in-depth Mortal Kombat's tutorial is
insanely good I don't think you should
underestimate the tutorial here yeah
those are the games most of the fighting
games with tutorials like okay just do
this move alright you do it like okay
that's cool but this actually shows you
why and how and what situations you want
to use it yeah because now when we go
into like practice mode we'll kind of
have a better idea yeah mashing all the
buttons I can I know when to use this
move or this combo string at this time
because the tutorial I could told you to
so I don't know I wouldn't underestimate
it like I almost want more yeah I was
very sure I mean was just one section of
terminators right isn't there like
multiple sections I think in this one
they show you like character specific
stuff but then they show you like
general combo stuff but yeah yeah yeah
building combos I kind of want to see
his crushing blows - I don't know which
one's actually a crushing blow and what
you need to do to get the blows you guys
should play a normal fight when you're
done seekies a fatality coin for the
second fatality yes we will yeah indeed
I am gonna happen to practice mode
though I kind of just at least want to
learn a combo too Before we jump into a
match so we're not totally lost someone
said that second variation is busted so
I kind of wanted a second variation
look how busted and I'll pick Cassie's
so you guys can see her wait where is it
do we need to buy it I definitely
downloaded it already
where can I choose my knee to customize
her oh yeah I forgot all right let me
just do that real quick okay cuz
somebody was asking in the chat about
Cassie Quinn so it's only fair to equip
these cost
kind of genetics
oh there it is yeah oh and we got a
couple of colors a lot of colors
actually but you know who that one is
nice too black and white kind of like
that one gives me and Domino by its long
wait the original Harlequin skin was red
and black right yeah okay that's the OG
one yeah we'll stick with the original
and then I actually don't know if I have
a skin appearance here but let's see oh
that was cool yeah oh and his arm is
exposed oh that's so cool I can totally
get behind that I was wondering if they
had one that was just his like what's on
his shirt on that one he's on fire
alright I kind of like the black t-shirt
ones yeah me too that one for a bit cool
all right
yeah I forgot about that I'm like such a
Capcom fighter where they have like
select the costume characters like looks
I must continue to learn learn all the
knowledge oh man I should have set it up
with the other variation I forgot yeah
you want you under the busted version
right oh no with the busted version is
not what the yeah the right that's okay
okay when do the other heroes release in
the mortal pack I think it's I think the
next one is in November so like next
month which is oh it might be wrong but
I think it's Sindel oh I think she is
next okay yeah I don't know the
these states here
December ok I want to play a spawn the
most honestly he does look super cool I
was making the thumbnail and I'm cool
okay so here here is the actual list of
dates for all of the upcoming DLC
playable characters for guys real quick
so we already got shang tsung night wolf
and terminator today for Kombat pack
holders and then Sindel is coming
November 26 the Joker is coming
available January 28th so that's the
next year and then spawn is the last one
with the pack of course March 17 so far
so far so it's all good though man he
looks so cool okay yeah I like yeah I
like the arm it's great this is my
little metal sound effect ooh that's
nice
yeah okay yeah their own uh put some
combos together shall we
so eliminate all humanity that was one
we learned that was really good names
are so good these two are great we I do
want to see oh I think I know why that
one's the better one right because
that's the one that has the the sticky
grenade that we saw oh the launchers
yeah I don't want reckoning I think
that's in the other the other version
yeah man okay I'm sorry you guys I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna I'm gonna go equip
the skin we want on variation to
triggering cry right I know it was like
it either is play already I know it has
to be set up perfectly though you guys
it's a process okay when you learn to
lab everything has to be perfect
oh man I got a lot of stuff okay
Iran building oh and he's got the
glasses too yeah this is even better Ray
Ban Arnold is best Arnold I'm actually
curious if they actually got his actual
voice because I think they got his face
but I think somebody else is doing his
voice okay cuz they copy his accent yeah
it's not a hundred percent accurate you
can sort of tell us not him they
definitely got his face done I don't
know if they actually if you actually
went into the office to get his face
scanned or if they like just took it off
oh hey I mean pictures or some
technology is advanced to nowadays
yeah like snapchat and everything all
right close so let's formulate some
combos before we hop into a match so I'm
going to tag these good strings they're
all actually kind of good but the ones
that we learned
that's the throw one and then some
special news nice I think these are our
abilities skeleton attacks are severely
restricted in this form and Terminator
has armor yeah chill out well that's his
fatal blow oh I'll do that too doesn't
you say chill out in a different movie
not the Terminator somebody confirmed
that for me isn't that from when he was
like that that evil villain that was the
ice guy in a different movie at the
bathhouse Falls
oh and it's like a meal the Batman movie
yeah okay yeah so that's all right mix
up okay man what was that sticky grenade
thing we saw I know that's that's the
one that's what we really need yeah that
starts everything how do I even access
to the endoskeleton there's no notation
for it it's not gorilla press it's not
this is it mr. freeze yeah yeah yeah mr.
freeze oh snap second fatality down
forward down plus four noise left to go
and check that out
wait so this
oh is that like a oh I can't - in this
mode and I see what they mean
I'm so confused skeleton one unless
that's just a part of Tammany I don't
know again and though skeleton is low at
home can you exit this or does it just
go away no I don't think you can oh you
have to get low enough I see I see okay
combo into a double amplified saw it off
you could it seems like you could but we
need to find the launcher into it or
actually home could just look like a
regular combo into this sawed-off see
I'm more I'm already like thinking
through which combos work okay we need
that launcher where the heck is that
line uh I'm looking I'm looking
it's got it it totally had that killer
instincts orbiter sticky grenade vibe he
like threw it on the ground and he
exploded and they plate launched upwards
yeah it's purple yeah
get out of that overhead it's really
seem like a good caching blow actually
like don't even see it like crime is
freaking out right I mean you know what
I'm gonna go hop in there not knowing
anything and then you're gonna be like
oh my god so bad hold on which already
knew but I'm like trying it loose I just
wanna know what this move is yeah we got
it we got to learn a little bit more
jump into a match you can't just be
mashing all the buttons I mean sure I
I'm good at mashing some buttons I just
want one combo system overload you can
do like jumping heavy kick to like a
sawed-off combo I guess it's like a
really easy one yeah cuz that jump in
heavy kickers like
such an easy start with brandy combo
yeah
again be pretty much anything after that
that's so cool like a juggle
I don't know what the requirement for
that Rogers Oh was that oh I'm a Demeter
again this yep
selector and they can restart real quick
or reset the oh yeah I should just turn
it on
[Music]
all right just meet them oh nice you
can't go for it
cool cool only works in real science I
see I see
ah man what is that move does anybody
know the input for that sticky grenade
launcher anybody can tell us that'd be
great
because we can't find I mean I saw it
like once and the little character
breakdown yeah it's like oh this will be
easy to find it's really cool he like
throws it onto the ground they explode
and launch upwards
okay so Lucas says I already see the
potential in t800 I got a massive him he
does have a lot of really cool stuff
already seem like his his range is a
little short except for his shotgun
obviously yes they did say he was a
close-range combat character right which
makes sense but he's got a ton of
overheads Oh special move and nearly
defeated and determining your rises back
up oh it's like Dark Phoenix Wow okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah except no it's
broken man the gurney is probably an
equippable move man so there's no
tournament standard yeah like you can't
use the grenade that's weird it's only
weird to me because in the combat
casting yeah it had I guess I guess they
were just showing it off but like it's
it seems like the entire move said
there's no real
launcher yeah so far actually I didn't
see like one combo attack that had
something of it we'll just go through
all these with you guys so that's
interesting
personally I don't like to practice
things that aren't like tournament legal
only because I you know right to go to
the tournament so I don't want to yeah
that has like so much that doesn't even
seem safe at all how's it please overall
but my recovery is 27 to you so it's
like zero okay oh yeah this one I just
have to go into the match with some good
old basics for you guys yeah I'll just
end everything in a shotgun all right
those sound effects are really
satisfying though I do want to see him
getting burned so then it's endoskeleton
comes out I wonder what the
qualifications are for you to get into
your Terminator mode that to be like
Shang Tsung's like throw or like
scorpion burning you or how does that
work to get your skin off alright
alright well use a fatal blow why don't
we I don't know what the qualifications
are for what do you need to do to get
the fatal blow we go one fatal blow
earlier with a shotgun but I don't know
how to do it and I feels like oh yeah
some of these will tell you Oh crashing
crushing blow sorry
yeah but fatal blow you can actually
just do right now that's a section you
should just do the fatal blow just to
see what it looks like yeah l 1 and R 2
I'd never eat like yeah whoo thumbs up
that's kind of cheesy but it is cool
that's pretty cool oh it's his third
variation I didn't see a third variation
where when we were looking I mean just
like before we yeah I only have these
two yeah well there's there's only two
variations you get to make your own
custom one after that so that's fine
we'll just we'll do it live yeah well
figure it out does he have his own story
actually yeah let's just see like the
first chapter see if there's any
cutscenes I'll be kind of cool oh wait
or is this general three oh yeah please
wait now why did we do this okay there
we go yeah I think I forgot it's like a
it's not character specific all right
cool let's just do some towers don't
want to fight some real people yet cuz
clearly you guys don't mean we're node
combos it's fine I forgive you guys so
this one's got some purple stuff in it
yeah
the variations you're picking from are
not tournament ones up these aren't oh
wow why would they do that you have to
go equip the tournament ones really that
can't be right we didn't this is the
first time you picked them up right yeah
from the get-go they're not tournament
legal I didn't even know no I don't
think so I think this proves how much
tournament more all combat I whenever I
go there and everything's already set up
yeah one and two because that's like the
og tournament legal setups
all right let's slap these variations on
shall we
or just make a new version so you don't
mess with them yeah you right oh those
icons are pretty cool okay it's got all
the way to the towers and then you quit
out I mean you guys owe me if I are
gonna get these rolling bear thing
rolling my underneath it's it that's
that's that's the big boy right there
[Music]
you're so close
boom
Oh ever forgot to change his shirt there
we go all right
variations saved I don't care if it's
not tournament League I don't care where
it came from
it's quips just all we need it up
classic classic mostly input for the
grenade I don't know we're gonna figure
it out right now on the spot all right
we're gonna face roll on the stake oh
yeah that's something will come out I'm
gonna let my button-mashing take the
lead here I don't need no consumable
nuba I may pause it just look at the
input real quick but cuz I must know
honestly that your need is gonna be a
game-changer
yeah that's a cool wait hold up this one
up alright back for oh I lost my shoddy
that's worth it alright it's fine it's
fine
I got a black button no no wait I put my
blog like I did oh my gosh oh god this
is already bad Oh dare you know okay
there's a grenade yeah
go upward I thought does a girl I'm on
here I think I have to hold different
favor blue combo something yeah my right
we got this it's so slow oh yeah you got
interrupted really easily oh oh boy got
it that's my anti-air yeah no clothes
right no okay do this oh oh I forgot
blah Quentin that's always the hardest
thing for me to remember better ain't
never home games yeah I like the whole
back of water
the best always got no guns he's just
got ya hoses okay let's figure this out
as we go along you guys skipping no
fights I need to learn uh-huh
neither of em really man now might let
go to shoddy combos it's all gone yeah
it's gone forever
okay oh you know okay there you go
okay I'll take it up little three Oh
wrong one definitely projectiles wow
he's so smart
[Music]
in a million damage
I know know who nice nice
Monty oh there you go oh I can't in
trouble them oh no not that one
oh yeah there's my look down medium -
wait I have a move like that it's one of
these oh okay yeah running back land on
my name down overheads I heard you like
over oh I let go blocks it's like three
types yeah okay wait like well let's
take it forward back or backward yeah
haebang I think the best part about this
is like these are like crazy ancient
beings all these powers and they're like
boom I got a motorcycle pretty great
pretty great I love the chunks I need
your shoes and your motorcycle all right
we're getting some way is kind of like
you're doing it I am finally things are
happening stuff is happening see the
fighting game around me like this is
painful to me right now jumping into
like um even though we're against
computers but the fact that like I could
take some time out and learn some combo
and then come back and like play better
but now I understand you like to see
this struggle it is entertaining I ain't
readin yeah we like to put on a queen to
get out of here it's possible but it's
fine this is working out also I've never
seen that rating costume it's really
cool that is a different version of rain
and I
oh man played this game enough so yeah
he's officially out now if you have the
Kombat pack and ah I heard you like
overheads with the shotgun next time I
want to see the crossing of combos out a
bit cool not that but I'll make it down
Beck's where or yeah that Thanks oh
forgot what it was oh I like it though
wait wait I'm stamping from up oh you're
right did it did it bad Raven oh I did
that there give me by accident
oh there we go
yeah I will take it oh oh he's onto my
gimmicks when I was cool it's like the
metalbend and stuff there else okay so
that's nice that was cool
so the grenade will stay out if you are
blocking yeah get hit the grenade oh go
away
let's make sense yeah oh wait what did
they say it was down forward down for
four I don't know yeah give us inputs
for the second fatality I think someone
said it earlier was like down forward
and then down four again so I'm getting
excited
in his robot form
alright we're making it through things
are slowly getting pieced together oh I
can still attack some of the stuff in
the mood with a regular game
might have to do that with two robots
against each other I just need to back
for an X that's the wash and said get
that did that on okey that would
apparently that's real BM right there
she's whole extra nonsense now wow so
fast I forgot me yeah you gotta get your
jabs out - there you go
it's like the can-can which is adding
more holes into my brain use a fatality
token I don't know how to use
dodge it lady Wow sure sure happening oh
my gosh that was crazy she is wild by
around - around - yeah tournament cool
blog Thanks I'm sure you have or what
nope that's right pretty easy people I
mean I would assume so I've never used
it before time I have some
only thing is is X fatality one and
circle fatality two or vice-versa
I don't know I don't want to waste a
token you get interrupted like oh my
gosh nice style on you girl no
nice block okay okay this is like mrs.
freeze versus mr. freeze okay
that projectile barriers really oh if I
um meter burn it explodes immediately
cool all right so hold block and then
hold circle
nope okay what's look at some matches in
the sour soul and it's not working guys
someone gave me the notation earlier let
me scroll it alright yeah middle down
forward down for so I'll try that next
time
so mid mid screen mid distance down for
already you know I'm gonna get to those
last wise and not be able to because I
remember when this game first came out
and I was shining playing body crazy
really dude
no no we broke already
yes yeah okay oh I was about to pop up
that's nice mix up oh man really really
why am i glowing said the endoskeleton
oh god no way you don't have that
get out looks really cool train that bit
later get away from me get over here
it's not pretty accurate now gee the
griddle MK special just a low jab no
it's cool all right final round that's
crazy
No
oh my gosh [__]
of course rush me down Rose everything
what a meanie I know this guy trying to
think which combo can be combo it into
his grenade can only think of shotgun
right let's do right back oh nice lock
I think I do I think I know you guys do
the okie throw grenade down away from
the attack
oh ho we do one thing that's not good
so I used it first round what a scrub
now we're gonna be able using this match
again and I still got the lead
barely shut up this guy's such a bully
[Music]
okay not black okay again oh my god I
don't know when it's pink stuff
Wow walk out tonight sure recovery is
pretty bad Wow get off me yeah oh god
the recovery is so bad ya know if you
like must have to do that on that down
there you go
there you go okay we're getting
somewhere
oh you compote into the grenade I meter
burned it to get it to explode instantly
trying to figure that out that is
something I've always hated an in-game
jumping over projectile is like
impossible okay fatality of a mitzvah
came down blow it down
now he has the perfect range down for a
downpour yeah big [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah whoo Rana kneecap Oh
dang-son came away with no legs banish
the shadow that was good I like that one
good payback I think I like that one
more than the first one for sure yeah me
too oh snap
totem I do like the Wraith portal
banished to the Shadow Realm we did it
y'all
yeah you did the Vidal II now we gotta
beat this without spending no coins see
we're efficient oh man I want to fight
her she's busted it's okay it's all
right
got are no lucky for them you got time
travel she has time travel and then
terminators time travel
[Music]
she's just cheap because she's not all
this other stuff going true boss battles
that is oh here we go here comes a
nonsense oh geez no no instant teleports
time control multiple projectiles yeah
wait not I don't want to fight myself
see even he knows come on come on Lady
fatality oh really
she's straight up fatality - yeah Wow
again some fun I know I've seen this
before
this for all of eternity so much that
you know when I was playing through the
story moving I was fighting here I was I
was having a bad time I saw that like so
many times
[Laughter]
oh my god is the teleport and there's
just no recovery on it do whatever she
wants what's oh my lord I don't know
what you guys gonna expect from me here
but it's not gonna be a win she is crazy
all right ladies get it get it yeah do
it every time she beats me yeah I know
right
chronic Oh where's your fatality to the
chalice morons is building right now
Wow they showed me a screen of what the
controls were and they're like hey
you're getting bodied right now take a
look at the controls how you block get
good
[Music]
Oh
that early oh yeah you could projectile
carry let's see if she knows the second
I Legos freaking block button she knows
what I hate about a eyes it's what you
like just staring each other down they
know exactly when you're gonna yeah okay
we're kind of gonna oh I'm so bad really
continuously doing that move given dust
boots okay come on back now girl oh God
they've got the t-rex oh god oh god oh
god she's just staring I know it's like
more terrifying than when she was
rushing me down wait I totally block
that well you can you can parry that
actually with the projectile carry I'm
pretty sure whoa there's so much block
damage
I know her she's so messed up
nice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no thank you
she's like my arms are tired from
constantly ripping your body apart oh
I'm gonna feed salad II the crap out of
here will he beat her you guys I know
you have no idea alright time to cheese
we're just gonna take this one step at a
time
yeah I wonder how much of the technology
does can be parried that's dance that
Ronald has no I did you much
[Laughter]
combos I like knockdown she probably
does I'm just not used I know I don't
want to oh my gosh that was kind of cool
though the impact of my means turned
into just a nose you need him thank you
yeah nice okay just like go to start and
retry skip all that just mix it up
between square triangle square and
square triangle X I'm like just trying
to do the most easiest
things possible good job
[Music]
sky rushing down a little bit you know
oh no I get over here what how did that
not so bells like thank you since I hit
him with a jab yeah okay okay
we've had more health this time than any
other time so far the dinosaur and I'm
slowly losing life oh my god oh my god
Oh God
no no no no we start match Oh baby oh my
gosh of course I'm not doing any combos
I can't knock it down you guys didn't
want me to go in the training mode so
let's see me suffer at the hands of
chronica all day not only is she a bully
but you guys are bullies it's all good
[Music]
that's so busted that is busted sounds
like that
freakin Virgil over here yeah Jackie's
been here more than chronic fear I know
how dare she I'm trying to preserve as
much life as I can
[Music]
no no yeah yeah I bet I am
hey I shouldn't even follow up after
that I did that much damage
what are you know ok she's doing
something else I don't do it I am like
starting to get a little bit more
familiar with his potential combos but
it's like she's suffocating me if I
can't even try to do that's no good Oh
God
okay cool
so oh and then they don't go away
rude no no double no yeah Chronicle rage
quit on me you guys that means I
definitely won that one alright what's
what this yeah
oh my gosh chefs in the chat yes in the
chat
permanent facepalm my fees in my palm
are now one oh my goodness that was
unfortunate now is the best I had done
so far
oh man that's a rip what a cruel cruel
world of course conquer story classic
Towers interesting
very interesting still hold the
mentality for real she dodged me you
guys I'm convinced now we gotta start
from the bottom again it's okay because
if chronic I just wasn't chronica some
of my combos would've definitely been
pretty nice yeah man crime really wants
to see me get bodied online convinced
he's like no no training go online get
destroyed
if you thought I really thought I wasn't
doing any combos now wait until
hopefully actually you guys I'm not
playing online because I'm saving it for
Friday because Ben and John Luke are
gonna be playing some inkay with you
guys on Friday so that's actually the
real reason why I haven't been doing it
okay so of course the one I need this
enough I have so much time to
nice that's not a but it's so cool
here's in the air for like three seconds
straight okay okay you need to cut it up
no I like right at the frame I did it no
no no no that's not the move that's not
okay yeah he reset me like an ass
oh man oh my goodness okay you know
scorpion was my little character because
of how easy his compass I Drive to do my
fatal blow you guys are all me knees
they won't let me do this half a combo I
learn oh my gosh he's full of his meters
just like that man so much recovery
after that
okay that's an octa yeah I tried to jump
over that come on come on yeah that does
grab in the air oh yeah I forgot fatal
blow is only available I liked that last
section
yeah I was like I would do mine on we
could
no no no can't get it to come out whoa I
got thunder it whoa it looked really
weird the blue stuff I had to jump after
I need that tasties do you sound bored
he's like the least of my worries at oh
wait your tickets to be a coffee Oh
wrong way no no no
whereas negan yes he was in Tekken that
is correct we were kind of just talking
about him a little bit ago before the
stream you're like you know bringing all
these TV and movie adaptations to the
game yeah I like it I might so like to
see how they convert a regular character
and feel like a fighting game character
you know the development process behind
me
[Music]
super unsafe stuff I'm really wondering
how spawn will turn out because I played
spawn we have a 3d iteration of spawn
yeah to degeneration
here's another fighting game besides
Soul Calibur maybe I'm the low beam over
and over thank ya multiple boots this
one wait wait why can't I do it
no that went so far
there you go Oh No how is little elbow
and reach I did for example
oh yeah we could join us some fights we
can make like a custom lobby with the
Ben yeah here let's go back
oh no we're not scared
we're just saving the goodness the
online goodness for Friday that's all
yeah conquer all right online yeah so on
Friday will be community Friday's or how
you guys fight us nmk gosh and I'm
versus pretty sure everybody well
anybody who has combat pack will have
yeah and I'm sure Xbox right that by
Friday too
[Music]
all right BAM all right all right Ben
come on in wait how do I know many
people go straight up to my friends list
it's a cool background yeah it's the
International Women's Day one okay
there is good all bingeing good things
are happening
I think no wait since when did this
become so difficult I don't know five
people the game I'm sorry but I'm an
xbox we gotta find uh-oh he's in here
okay aha aha sorry Dillon Friday Dillon
Friday come back on Friday and you got
75 ping yeah nothing fires up 70
milliseconds yeah all right on a
connection
yeah I mean the grenade is pretty cool
but I kind of missed that the shotgun I
can walk around what if you can do a
shotgun as an area oh cool Ben's using
the endoskeleton one so we'll actually
get to see some of the other stuff yes I
know Benson in that training mode with
the terminator noise like you'll know
what he's doing
well oh yes a street that's further oh
wow pretty good damage yeah oh whoa nice
ah I keep getting that one
that's a very specific range of that
grenade goes yeah I can do the clothes
I'm just not but he has a ton of
overheads no oh oh I can enjoy
the toes Dylan will we'll be playing
again on Friday yeah join us on Friday
we promise how long is community
Friday's it's the same thing okay the
house and I let's specifically just to
play with you guys so join us again on
Friday will be playing Terminator we
play with you guys I guess that's the
mix-up like if you don't know if you're
gonna amplifier oh oh oh look at that
super armor that was crazy that's really
intimidating that might be part of Oh
endoskeleton whoa I was really cool
he does have some intro clips against
himself to look like he'll ask himself
like what model are you because the
mission changed that's pretty cool so I
guess there would be multiple huh
I don't know the the Terminator lore but
is there multiple I know there's like t8
hundreds or P 8000 or never like there
like multiple yeah terminate the sermon
generic intro is it okay that combo
always looks really cool
[Applause]
not these dumb fertile ground confirm
into the grenade that's like the
weighted throws a search even yeah the
thorough escape window is pretty short a
lot of budding heads of mash I like the
strategic teabag in the beginning
t800 and t 850 okay is 850 the the
liquid one back he fights in Terminator
2 or 3 I don't know I'm a terminator
scrub but I know there's that other evil
evil terminator oh why can't I oh my god
I think so clunky it's like against
everything I know fighting game way yeah
I mean I like Mortal Kombat but just me
personally it's not my type of fighting
game I just the hold the legs apart
the button block kind of
just too much of an anime fighter I need
my air dashes
I need my back two blocks they say that
moves one frame but I haven't been able
to get it out a reaction one Gary yeah
pretty much
shotgun uppercut
my like pinky is already sore from
holding the block button oh really
I'm like yeah that's why I've been
playing Mortal Kombat on controller
actually that was actually a reason why
I tried to play injustice at one point
cuz i like MK seems cool but you don't
have to hold a button to block and like
you I think there's a lot of action a
lot of pros who play MK on controller
more than on a stick yeah so no like
Street Fighter obviously it's like you
know stick is like the way to go or if
you like Mortal Kombat is controller
seems okay
where's the endoskeleton huh we had it
for a second earlier I don't know how we
trigger it though yeah the shotgun is
great yeah kind of makes me not really
want to use this version because the
shotgun is so many friends yeah ah wow
that one came out interesting yeah I
feel like in this game since a lot of
emotions are just like back forward if
you're walking backward and you press a
button you'll get that movie yeah okay
yeah I think you parried that yeah I did
I didn't do anything I just ate it I
guess yeah I'm hyped for the new guilty
gear - oh my gosh it looks so pretty
see it's not one frame I don't believe
it's one frame
whoa okay that's cool
oh wow throw a lotta wake up like just
so plays other characters right now or
just wanting to show off her man you
alright GG has been good stuff I like
that both of us was literally doing the
same like three hit regular combo I feel
like it's alright yeah exactly come back
on Friday you guys cuz I'm Friday yeah
actually had some chance and Tre anymore
delirious like hot well not me Cicely
Ben and John Luke cuz they're the ones
who'll be playing on Friday but yeah if
you guys want to play some online
matches go ahead and wait for a Friday
laughs it's all Friday unless they're
playing something else but last I heard
they were playing say okay but yeah
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
checking out some Terminator with us
yeah it was a good time can't wait to
see what the community does at this
character and to see you like you know
actual combos couple things yeah it
seems like there's a lot of variation
questions I could throw out there right
now because I'm not really sure what's
tournament legal or not but the grenade
was pretty cool I got to see it in
action though but that shotgun that
shotguns really cool bang
all right you guys we're out of here at
see ya next time